يواصل وزير الخارجية الأمريكي أنتوني بلينكين
جولته في الشرق الأوسط،
ويقول إنه أوضح لإسرائيل أنه
يجب السماح للفلسطينيين في غزة بالعودة
إلى منازلهم بمجرد أن تسمح
الظروف بذلك، وبينما
تقول إسرائيل مراراً وتكراراً إنها تنتقل إلى حل
جديد  مرحلة أقل شدة من الحرب،
القصف العنيف على المنطقة لا يزال
مستمرًا حتى الآن، يقول جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي إنه يهدف إلى
التناسب والدقة في
عملياته العسكرية، ضيفنا التالي
الليلة يرسم صورة مختلفة تمامًا،
يال أبراهام هو مراسل استقصائي لمجلة
بلس 972 الإسرائيلية التي
تشارك في نشرها.  يديرها إسرائيليون وفلسطينيون
وينضم إلي من تل أبيب لمناقشة
تقاريره أه يال شكرا جزيلا
لانضمامك إلينا الآن أه تحقيقك
يناقش اقتباس جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
التفويض الموسع لقصف الأهداف غير العسكرية
واقتباس تخفيف
القيود المتعلقة بالمدنيين المتوقعين
تحدث إلينا الضحايا عما
وجدته في تقاريرك وكيف يتناقض ذلك
مع الطريقة التي يقول بها الجيش الإسرائيلي إنه
يدير هذه الحرب من وجهة
نظرك، نعم، لذلك وجدت ثلاثة أشياء رئيسية،
الأول هو أن الجيش
تخلى تمامًا عن البروتوكولات السابقة
التي كانت قائمة  تهدف إلى تنظيم
قتل المدنيين الفلسطينيين، لذلك بالنسبة
لهذه العملية، على سبيل المثال، في
ضربات الاغتيال التي تستهدف كبار قادة
حماس، أخبرتني مصادر استخباراتية
أن الجيش
يقتل عن عمد مئات عدة
مئات من المدنيين الفلسطينيين في كل
محاولة اغتيال،
والشيء الثاني هو أن الجيش
الاعتماد بشكل كبير على
الذكاء الاصطناعي لتوليد أهداف لمثل
هذه الاغتيالات مع القليل جدًا من
الإشراف البشري وفقًا للمصادر،
وأخيراً آخر شيء هو أن هناك
هذا المفهوم في الجيش يسمى
أهداف القوة وهي أهداف يتم
ضربها ليس لقيمتها العسكرية ولكن
لأنها  طريقة لضرب الروح المعنوية في
غزة وجعل المدنيين
يضغطون على حماس وتحقيقي
على مجلة plus 972 والمكالمات المحلية
يعتمد على سبعة مصادر استخباراتية وأنا
مستمر في الحديث مع هذه
المصادر الاستخبارية أه أيضا أه في
الأسابيع القليلة الماضية  أريد أن أسأل المزيد عن
دون الكشف عن مصادرك أم فقط
نوع المصادر التي لديك
والوصول إليها ولماذا لديهم حق
الوصول الذي يقومون به، يجب أن نعرف أن
تقارير CNN لا يمكنها تأكيد أه
تحقيقك ونتائجه أه جيش
الدفاع الإسرائيلي نحن  يجب أن أشير إلى أنه يقول في بيان
أنهم ملتزمون بالقانون
الدولي ويتصرفون وفقًا
له، وبذلك يهاجمون
أهدافًا عسكرية ولا يهاجمون المدنيين
ويسعى أيضًا إلى تقليل
الخسائر في صفوف المدنيين إلى الحد الأدنى، لقد قلت شيئًا في وقت سابق
عالق في ذهني أم أنا
مشاهدينا ليسوا خبراء عسكريين أيضًا، ولكننا
كنا نشاهد هذه الحرب ما يقرب من 247
خلال الأشهر الثلاثة الماضية وهي تتكشف على شاشة
التلفزيون، كيف
تدير إسرائيل هذه الحرب، ومن الواضح أنها على
نطاق أوسع بكثير في أعقاب
الهجوم الإرهابي المروع الرهيب الذي وقع في 7 أكتوبر
لكنها في جيب وهي ضد
جماعة إرهابية، ومن المألوف جدًا
كيف يديرون هذه الحرب مع
حماس بشكل مختلف عما فعلوه في
الحروب الماضية، نعم، لذا أعني أنني يجب أن أقول
إنك تعرف ذلك ردًا على
قول الجيش ذلك  إنها تفعل كل ما في
وسعها لتقليل
الخسائر في صفوف المدنيين إلى الحد الأدنى، هذا غير صحيح وأنا
أقول إنه غير صحيح لأنك تعلم أنني
تحدثت هذا الأسبوع فقط
مع ما يقرب من ثلاثة ضباط استخبارات إسرائيليين
كانوا يخططون بالفعل
لهذه الأهداف  خلال الأشهر القليلة الماضية
ويقولون لي أن
الجو العام هو جو لا
معنى فيه للحياة الفلسطينية إلا القليل جدًا وللإجابة على سؤالك
أعني البروتوكولات السابقة التي كانت
معمول بها على سبيل المثال في الحروب السابقة في
محاولة اغتيال ضد  أحد كبار
قادة حماس، عادة لا
يسمحون بقتل أكثر من خمسة مدنيين،
وأحيانًا عدة عشرات. الآن في
هذه العملية، يُقتل عدة
مئات من المدنيين الفلسطينيين
في كل محاولة اغتيال، وكنوع
من القاعدة الشاملة لأي نوع من عمليات
الاغتيال، يصل عدد الضربات إلى ما بين 15 شخصًا.  إلى
20 مدنيًا فلسطينيًا أصبح الآن استخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي هائلاً للغاية في
هذه العملية، وبحلول الأسبوع الثاني،
أصبحت معظم عملية إنشاء الهدف وفقًا للمصادر
آلية بالفعل، وقالت المصادر التي كانت
هناك وكانت تقوم بتشغيل هذه
الآلات المستهدفة التي تم إنشاؤها باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي:  معظم
الأهداف التي تم إنشاؤها كانت من صغار
نشطاء حماس الذين تم قصفهم مرة أخرى
عندما كانوا في منازلهم ولم
يقتلهم فقط بل ما يصل إلى ما بين 15 إلى 20
مدنيًا فلسطينيًا عائلات بأكملها
من حولهم، تذكر هذا، ليس هذا،
لم يكن هذا موجودًا في السابق  الحروب،
نعم، أنا سعيد لأنك طرحت
الذكاء الاصطناعي ودوره في
هذه الحرب، فأنت تكتب على وجه التحديد عن
أداة تسمى "الإنجيل"، أخبرنا المزيد
عن كيفية
استخدامها بالتأكيد، لذا فإن الإنجيل هو مجرد
نظام واحد من بين عدة أنظمة تعمل
بشكل أساسي  أم أم قم بتأليف هذه
الآلات التي تصنع الأهداف وما يفعلونه
بمراقبته، فهم يجمعون المعلومات من
جميع سكان غزة، لذلك 2.3
مليون شخص ويحسبون
احتمال أن يكون فرد معين
مرتبطًا بحماس
واحتمال أن يكون فرد معين
مرتبطًا بـ  رقم هاتف معين
على سبيل المثال، وهم يفعلون ذلك على
نطاق واسع مما يولد مئات
الأهداف كل يوم. أخبرتني المصادر الآن
أن الجيش يعرف أن
هذه الأنظمة ليست دقيقة دائمًا وأن
السياسة ليست سياسة خالية من الأخطاء التي
علق عليها الجيش  إلى
مقالتي وقلت إن الإنسان دائمًا
على اطلاع بالذكاء الاصطناعي
وسأعطيك مثالًا
حسنًا، تم تشغيل Meta Source مؤخرًا
لهذه الآلات وأخبرني أنه
يقصف عشرات المنازل كل يوم
وسألته  كم عدد هذه المنازل التي تم
إنشاؤها بواسطة الذكاء الاصطناعي
كأهداف للاغتيال
وقال لي كل منهم يجب أن أعطيه
الضوء الأخضر وسألته جيدًا كم من
الوقت قضيته في كل هدف في
الإشراف على ما أنشأته الآلة وما الذي صنعته
الآلة؟  قال المصدر إنه كانت هناك أسابيع
كان هناك الكثير من الضغط
لإنشاء أكبر عدد ممكن من الأهداف لدرجة أنه
أمضى 20 ثانية لكل هدف وكان
الإشراف هو التحقق مما إذا كان الذكاء الاصطناعي
يولد الهدف للاغتيال
هو ذكر أو أنثى إذا كان أنثى
إنهم يعلمون أنه خطأ ارتكبه الذكاء الاصطناعي بالتأكيد
لأنه ليس من المفترض أن
يتم إنشاء النساء كأهداف وإذا كان
ذكرًا فسيأذنون بذلك
أه لأنه وفقًا لذلك
المصدر لأنه ليس 100% ولكن
من المحتمل أن يكون هذا هو  شخص من حماس،
وفي كل واحدة من هذه الضربات التي
تم التصريح بها، لدينا مدنيون
يُقتلون أيضًا، كما ذكرت كل ما ذكرته
سابقًا ومرة ​​أخرى، لا أريد
تعريض مصادرك للخطر ولكني رأيت في
مقابلة أجريت مؤخرًا أنك ستحصل على معلومات  أن
هذه مصادر إما
مرتبطة بالجيش أو مرتبطة
بهذه العمليات وتريد
ضمان أمن وسلامة إسرائيل،
وقد قيل لماذا
يختارون التحدث معك حول هذا الأمر
الآن، نعم إنه سؤال رائع و
أعتقد أنك تعرف أن التحدث إلى هذه المصادر
مثلهم جميعًا بعد حدوث الصدمة في 7 أكتوبر،
فأنت تعرف
الفظائع التي قاموا بها على الفور،
بعضهم تطوع للذهاب إلى
الجيش، وبعضهم في
الاحتياط
وتدريجيًا كانوا كذلك  لقد
صدمت بصراحة بما طلب منهم
القيام به، وعدد الأشخاص الذين
صدموا ولكن مدى
عدم التناسب، وأعتقد أن الكثير
منهم شعروا
بمسؤولية حقيقية لمشاركة هذه
المعلومات مع الجمهور الإسرائيلي
ومع الجمهور الدولي و
خاصة مع الولايات المتحدة التي
تمول هذه الحرب إلى حد كبير لأن هناك
تفاوتًا كبيرًا في كل مرة أنتهي فيها من
محادثة مع مصدر ذكي لا
أستطيع أن أصدق التفاوت بين
الطريقة التي يتم بها تصوير هذه الحرب
في وسائل الإعلام والطريقة التي يتم بها
فعليًا  موجود على الأرض وأعتقد أن
الكثير من المصادر شعرت بمسؤولية
تغيير ذلك للحديث عنه